I think there's truth and it's it's so
difficult because 50 50 custody would be
something like where and maybe like
something to protect men from not
getting absolutely wrecked with like
child support spouses well we should
just get rid of no-fault divorce agreed
all right banished birth control too
this is oh my God yes take away repeal
the 19th this is what what feminists are
arguing we did a segment on no fault
divorce and then they started ragging on
us and they gave Sheamus's quote to Ian
Ian it was one of my best quotes ever
they gave it to even Ian Crossland even
cross even cross even got a good quote
what they're arguing is that marriage is
now better because women and men can
both of them can just leave whenever
they want that's what makes them better
that's literally not marriage so my
point is okay fine here's here's what I
want to say to all of those feminists
whatever it is you have now let's keep
it exactly the way it is but we'll
create something called super marriage
and if after you're married you decide
to enter a super marriage now you can't
get divorced without a valid reason
problem solved yeah I mean look I agree
with you that we need to end no fault
divorce I said this this is one of the
things that Jezebel was so core uh
horrified by that they quoted it and
gave the quote to Ian Crossland but
people people talk about how many
marriages fail and if you know if we had
no we removed no fault divorce so many
people would be stuck in these marriages
all right well they don't consider is
that people are less cautious about who
they choose to marry because divorce is
an option and also because we live in a
culture where people do have sex before
they're married they end up being
blinded by the sex they don't evaluate
the person objectively they end up
become becoming Bond by all the chemical
reactions that happen in their brain
when they have sex with somebody and so
you end up making really bad decisions
people say well if we change the
cultural Paradigm what what about all
these people who made these bad
decisions there's going to be fewer of
them there will be fewer people making
those kinds of decisions
I I was going to answer your question um
about porn and if it's because I think
it is doing is and I'd love to talk more
about no-fault divorce too it burns my
mind almost every day
um that I think it is helping young
people get their aggression out and
maybe it's it's it's winding Tighter and
Tighter and Tighter until it explodes
but a lot of times young sexless men
they just get put into the military to
go kill and I I'm not seeing that now I
mean it's it's drastic in the other
direction you might argue that nobody or
hardly anybody wants to go fight so
maybe it's the completely depleted the
testosterone of the youth maybe we need
enforced a monogamy actually I have
another question so the more the more
women have been in charge of their own
mate selection the more Partners we've
had so is there something about women
that's actually not monogamous well no
because I think what you're touching I
mean those those things are correlated
right so
um that's correlated with the Advent of
reliable methods of artificial
contraceptive uh and even even started
before like the birth rate started
decline before it actually like because
a lot of people think it was the 60s but
it's actually been declining since the
1800s and in 1920 like we do see a dip
in the birth rate and like they
attribute that to women like living in
an apartment outside like by herself or
before she would go straight from like
her parents house to her husband's house
oh wow so so it's interesting like when
you think about it like it did like
women like then began to have more
Partners sexually so it's like it seems
like like throughout history like
they've just been trying to like keep
women from like not to be so
you're saying that women should be
allowed to own property
do I actually have never thought about
that question
um
I like it I don't know I haven't thought
about it but I think what's been pretty
well understood by basically every
culture through all of history is like
men are gonna try to have sex right men
are going to try to persuade women to
have sex with them and so societies have
understood that we need to get women to
be really good at saying no to this uh
or else everyone's just going to be
having sex outside of marriage you're
gonna have a lot of illegitimate
children a lot of infanticide and
abortion which is what ended up
happening uh that's that's actually not
hyperbolic if you look at ancient Rome
the more sexually licentious people came
the more in fantasized there was I mean
it's a reality oh at that point do you
think it would be better for you or just
for women in general to have like three
kids with three different phenomenal
dudes or three kids with one guy I would
say three kids with one guy then I well
I guess I guess you have to if you think
about it from like a gene perspective
you probably get better like quality
jeans I'd imagine if you said they're
like hi but like for yeah but for a
society no like the one that's like
saying let me let me try different guys
three different guys because one of the
kids will succeed instead of being like
let's just have kids together and raise
them I'm not I'm just I'm playing
Devil's Advocate I'm like
say that this man's hard to find you're
gonna find three and then they're all
gonna be with the same woman
I want to pull up the story from the New
York Post because I love this making
women look dumb is a new disturbing
podcast Trend and I'd like for us I'd
like to get my mouth here
uh here's a picture from the whatever
podcast and there's uh Mary Morgan from
uh pop culture crisis they're sitting
with the crew and then you've got uh
Destiny hanging out and uh you know why
I I take issue with this article
because if the whatever podcast has Mary
on the show and she is based and very
smart how are they making women look
dumb when they have women on who also
criticize other women and they criticize
each other like so so who are they
arguing is being made to look dumb are
they arguing the women he brings on are
making Mary look dumb making you Pearl
look dumb I would like to say I was very
offended when I saw this because they
didn't include my podcast I don't know
why my picture wasn't there too
I just but but I actually I think you're
right though I think it's stupid like
women make themselves look stupid I
didn't do like I so I've I've made
fun of the whatever podcast like I did a
cartoon about it I understand why it
exists I do understand it
yes yeah yeah that was me yes yes that
was oh that was so funny thank you I'm
really glad you enjoyed that that was uh
but I I think that
my my view of it and maybe it's changed
a little bit uh recently actually you
have this podcast and these young women
who kind of are very young and they just
regurgitate whatever the culture tells
them goes on this show then you've a guy
who's in his 30s who obviously knows
better because he's a guy in his 30s and
he explains to them if they're wrong and
then it gets clipped and it goes viral
and it's like look at this uh dumb girl
one thing I was actually very
I'll say
um impressed by maybe something that
made me feel a little optimistic was
that when the roles were reversed and
Lila Rose was on that show and her is
like a good traditionalist woman she was
arguing with a man who was trying to
justify sleeping around pretty much
everyone in the comments was on her side
and every clip I saw of that video was
people praising her and so it does look
like even though the targets are usually
women what people on this who are
watching these podcasts are upset about
uh is the sexual Revolution and its
consequences and they don't like when
people kind of engage in these
rationalizations for this type of
behavior yeah yeah you know you know
what it is funny thing uh I will point
out though a trend on Instagram is for
women to make fake podcast Clips have
you noticed this no no on Instagram
female influencers will buy these
microphones and then they'll say
something
that's genius yeah yeah it'll be a clip
it'll just be them talking to one and
they'll say something like I think that
men should be good providers and too
many women you know insert opinion and
that's the end of the clip and it's got
a mini million views why do I even do my
whole hour-long podcast why do we do
this Tim let's just make Clips let's
make fake shorts for YouTube oh that's
crazy I think that the older women are
more delusional
well it's like I just think they're
Dumber on myself hold on when you say
older women do you mean older women or
like older women who are single because
that's also two separate categories
right um
I mean I'd say the majority of people
that go on the shows are single okay so
but like I thought you're gonna say
you're dumb but I just wanna I just want
to point this out but I I would just
sorry no no finish your point I would
just say that I think that the older
women are more delusional on my show and
I think that's a lot of times like why
men date younger because they're like
thinking they'll be like better when
they're older but they're they're just
as delusional so look at this New York
Post says while only fans model
Nicolette Nicole admitted that her
appearance on the podcast was to bolster
her own following she told Vice the
clips were definitely chosen to create
controversy and make her look dominant
shamer no no the only thing I want to
point out is calling somebody on only
fans a model yeah
no but you know what makes me mad okay
because what the girls will do is
they'll go on the show and then after
they'll play victim like oh boo hoo poor
me they've done this on my show so many
times where like they'll come on and
then they'll they'll they'll sometimes
say out straight out missandrist
misandristic statements and then go back
later and say oh I'm a victim blah blah
blah when it's like if you say dumb
like there's so many women that go on
these shows and don't go viral and don't
say stupid and actually go viral
for the right reasons but if you go
viral for saying something stupid that's
that's your own fault well that's the
thing they say uh so the the article
it's being excited by the New York Post
is vice and their subhead is the
whatever podcast is baked you can stop
falling for it no it isn't they had Lila
Rose and Mary Morgan on that show where
are the clips making fun of them they're
not in fact the clips are praising them
the clip of Lila went viral because she
was like telling a guy off and then
people are like wow she's very smart
even she like she wasn't telling him off
he was trying to tell her often she was
just very calmly like stating her
position
was praising her yes
and it's funny because I saw one of
these red pill channels posted to try to
shame her they're like oh this woman
tries to tell this Alpha what's what but
all of the comments on their Channel
were like no she's right like this guy's
completely wrong what Vice is actually
doing is saying stop making us look dumb
because we're dumb well they're no no
they're saying stop making the sexual
Revolution look bad because if this was
a bunch of left-wing men talking down to
women who were Trad wives and saying
you're an idiot who's missing out on
what you should be doing in life they
would say this podcast is great you
think do you think that it's women
should be like I think what happens a
lot of people get offended is the
thought that a woman is supposed to be
raising kids you're you are your job in
life is to be a wife and a mother and
like not everybody wants that I mean
maybe you might maybe people will argue
that every woman deep down does want
that the majority of women do want that
I would say I I think are they surveyed
childless women or like it was like 80
or something 85 said they wanted kids I
can't remember the actual study I think
the issue is like they can't find the
right guy to have kids with or the guy
that they want
and like that and usually when I like I
talk to girls on the show they'll say
like I'm happy single or I'm happy not
having kids and I'll like if I ask
further questions and say like what
about if you found like the guy that
meets all your criteria and the majority
of the time they'll say yes yeah I I
remember I just want to mention this I
was at a bar with my my uncle my cousin
were visiting and so we were all at the
bar and her and I were the same age so
we must have been like 22 23 at the time
we're talking to this bartender who's
probably in her 40s and my cousin says
you know I'm like never gonna have kids
and the bartender's like how old are you
she's like I'm 22 and the bartender goes
shut up Scotty's like shut up you're 22.
you have no
idea what you want no time my
two-year-olds should and they I agree
that they should but in this culture
they don't and if someone is telling you
like I know I don't want to have kids
here's the thing if they're not saying I
will sacrifice having a family and
sacrifice having children because there
is a broader Noble goal which I wish to
achieve then okay I think that's a
person who probably does know what they
want and can take you can take seriously
but if they're saying I know in my early
20s I don't want to have kids and it's
for selfish reasons okay this is just
someone who's immature that's not like a
well thought out Life Plan that's I want
to do things that make me feel good
instead of thinking about what I can
contribute as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible